[Dogs barking]
I’m Mark Duplass and I play Pretzel
on the new Apple TV+ original series
Pretzel and the Puppies.
[Dogs barking] You guys are big readers!
Join us for our Pretzel Read-Along.
Story time! Story time!
[Dogs barking]
All right, now I’m going to read Pretzel
by Margret Rey with pictures by H.A. Rey.
One morning in May
five little dachshunds were born.
One of them was Pretzel. Look how cute he is!
[Dogs barking]
Who sees Pretzel?
Which one is – that’s it! That is Pretzel.
That was impressive.
Come on, pups. Paws up!
[Dogs barking] Yeah!
They grew up the way puppies do,
and they all looked exactly the same for the first few weeks.
But after nine weeks Pretzel
suddenly started growing –
and growing –
and growing.
He grew much longer than any of his brothers or sisters.
And when he was fully grown,
he had become the longest dachshund in the world!
What about us?
Are we long enough?
Pretzel was very pleased with himself because
it is very distinguished for a dachshund to be so long.
I love it!
When he was one year old
(a dachshund is grown up at that age)
he won the Blue Ribbon at the Dog Show
which means that everybody considered him
the best looking dog of all.
All the dogs admired him,
and all the people admired him, too.
Only Greta didn’t.
It’s tough when they don’t love you back.
Greta was the little dachshund from across the street.
Pretzel was in love with her and he wanted to marry her.
[Greta howling]
But Greta, well, she just laughed at him.
“I don’t care for long dogs,” she said.
Wait, what?
“But it is very distinguished for a dachshund
to be so long and I
won the Blue Ribbon at the Dog Show,” said Pretzel.
“I still don’t care,” said Greta.
[Dogs barking] She still doesn’t care.
[Dogs barking] What’s it going to take?
[Groan]
Pretzel was hurt, but he did not show it.
“Please marry me,” he said. “Please!”
[Dogs barking] Yes, he was begging!
[Dogs barking] “Please, please marry me!
And I will do anything for you,” he said.
“Prove it,” said Greta, and went away.
So, Pretzel set out to prove it.
Now, that sure makes my tail wag!
First, he bought Greta a nice bone.
You guys like bones? Look at that bone.
[Dogs barking] Yummy bone!
[Gasp] For me?
“Thanks for the bone,” said Greta,
“but I won’t marry you for that. I don’t care for long dogs.”
Then she ate the bone
and then she kind of forgot about Pretzel.
Well, Pretzel had to try something else.
He gave her the lovely green rubber ball
he had been given for his birthday.
“Thank you,” said Greta,
“but I still won’t marry you because I don’t care for long dogs.
Besides everybody can give presents!”
And she ran away with the ball.
[Dog whines] Who would do that?
Who would do such a thing?
“Look what I can do! Nobody except me can do that!”
said Pretzel, when they met again.
And this is what he did.
All right, who can make a Pretzel? Let’s see it.
Kind of, you do a little twisty thing? You know?
Don’t get yourself all tied up in knots!
“Not bad,” said Greta.
“Your name certainly fits you.
But I like pretzels at the baker’s better,
and I still don’t care for long dogs.”
Pretzel was very unhappy.
Some weeks had passed, and Greta hadn’t even spoken to Pretzel.
One day,
while she was playing with her green ball, it bounced away.
Look!
[Dog whines]
Greta tried to catch it, and boomps!
They both landed in a hole! Can you believe it?
It’s scary!
What’s going to happen? Let’s figure it out. Okay, okay.
We’ll get there. I know you’re excited.
You’re literally salivating to figure out what happens next.
Greta tried to get out of the hole, but she couldn’t.
It was much too deep.
She was terribly scared.
If nobody came to save her she might never, never…
Just then
Pretzel’s face appeared over the edge of the hole.
“I’ll get you out of there!” he shouted.
(He had watched Greta all the time and now he rushed to help her.)
How good
that Pretzel
was long!
“I believe you saved my life.
You are wonderful!” said Greta with a sigh.
“Will you marry me now?” asked Pretzel.
What’s going to happen?
[Dogs bark] What’s going to happen? I know, I know –
it’s exciting! I know!
“I will,” said Greta, “but not for your length!”
So, they kissed each other, and they got married,
and one morning in May
five little dachshunds were born.
[Dogs howl]
[Dogs bark] Look at the puppies! Look!
Yeah, that’s you guys!
The end.
[Dogs bark]
Yay! Yeah! Woo!
You want another story? I mean, when does it end?
You’re going to have to watch the show.
They can’t get enough.